tammy faye
what'd you do hello mother this is jim
baker
my husband
it's all part of our mission to help
people anyone who's hurting or they feel
like they've been left out
god has a plan for us what'd he tell you
to do this time
jim will preach and i'll sing
god does not want us to be poor
of pleasure now god has a voice in this
fight
who's he fighting liberal agenda
homosexual agenda
faith isn't political you can't talk to
him like that
jerry falwell is a powerful man tammy
faye she's a firecracker jim
if everyone watching could double their
pledge
just for one month god loves you
he really does
we're not doing anything wrong though
is that a question
[Music]
tammy and i are undergoing the most
vicious attacks
serving god don't feel like it should be
a money-making opportunity
you know when i saw that clipping with
my face on it i thought for a second
that you were proud of me
or tammy faye you follow blindly
in the end all you are is blind these
eyes
i just want to love people cry every
night
the devil's coming for me tammy can we
talk about satan leader jim
steve is a patient of aids i can't look
at this you need to get her under
control
i built you an empire i built you an
empire
some people they're just hurting so bad
and we just need to love them
i want to put my arm around you and i
want to put my arms around you tammy i
won't go forward looking in the rearview
mirror of my life
this is who i am
[Music]
you